2015, NOTHING'S REALLY HAPPENED.
IT'S A TOUGH ONE.
AS I SAY, IT'S A PART OF THE
OVERALL PICTURE.
>> STAND BY, I WANT TO BRING IF
MELISSA BELL.
SOME PEOPLE ARE SUSPECT LATEING
WHAT PUTIN'S NEXT MOVE COULD BE.
BUT IT LOOKS AS THOUGH RUSSIA OR
UKRAINE'S RATHER, CLIMATE, THE
WEATHER FORECAST COULD, INDEED,
BE A GOOD PLA ES TO START?
>> Reporter: IT'S WONDERFUL THAT
SOMETHING LIKE THAT COULD HAVE
AN IMPACT.
PICKING UP FROM WHAT NIC IS
SAYING ALL THIS TALK ABOUT THE
MINSK AGREEMENT, WHETHER A
SOLUTION COULD BE FOUND WHEN YOU
CRANE.
EVERYTHING IS GOING ON, ON THE
OUTSIDE, MORE THAN 2,000 TROOPS
FROM AMERICAN INTELLIGENCE SENT
WITHIN SIX HOURS AND SIX SHIPS
TO THE BLACK SEA.
THAT MILITARY BUILDUP FAR FROM
ENDING CONTINUES TO ESCALATE.
THAT, OF COURSE, CONTINUES TO
RAISE ATTENTION INSIDE THE
COUNTRY.
EVEN THOUGH WE HAVE BEEN HEARING
FROM THE FOREIGN MINISTER
SAYING, WE WERE PROMISED IN
MID-JANUARY, EP OF JANUARY, WE
ARE STILL TALKING, DIPLOMACY IS
WORKING, FOR THE TIME BEING,
THOSE DIPLOMATIC CHANNELS NEED
TO BE OPENED.
THEY ARE FUNCTIONING AND KEEPING
THE TROOPS ON THE RIGHT SIDE OF
THE BORDER A. LOT OF INTENTION
OF VLADIMIR PUTIN APPEARS TO DO
NEXT, THE IMPACT OF THE
CONDITIONS ON THE GROUND, THE
CLIMACTIC IMPACT.
ACCORDING TO LATEST DATA,
TEMPERATURES ARE RUNNING BETWEEN
ONE AND 3 DEGREES CELSIUS HIGHER
THAN THE 30-YEAR AVERAGE.
THAT JUST MIGHT MAKE A
DIFFERENCE TO ANY RUSSIAN
MILITARY OFFENSIVE.
>> THE RULES IN OCCUPYING THE
WHOLE COUNTRY, PARTICULARLY FROM
THE NORTH IN BELARUS, HE'S GOING
TO HAVE TO WAIT A BIT.
THE GROUND IS FROZE RON.
A RUSSIAN OFFENSIVE NEEDS FROZEN
GROUND GIVEN UKRAINE'S
LANDSCAPE.
>> PROMINENT TERRAIN INCLUDES
FLAT OPENED PLAINS AND THERE ARE
AN ABUNDANCE OF RIVERS AND LAKES
AND A HIGH WATER TALK.
WHEN THAT HIGH WATER TABLE
FREEZES, IT MAKES IT FOR OPTIMAL
CONDITIONS FOR CROSS-COUNTRY
TRACK AND WHEEL VEHICLE
MANEUVER.
>> Reporter: IT'S NOT SO MUCH
THAT MODERN TENTS GET BOGGED
DOWN IN WET POSITIONS, BUT THE
SPORT THEY NEED CAN DO.
>> MORE IMPORTANTLY THAN THE
TRACK VEHICLES, THEMSELVES, IS
WHAT THEY NEED TO SUSTAIN
THEMSELVES, WHICH IS FUEL AND
AMMUNITION, WHICH ARE VERY HEAVY
AND ARE GENERALLY CARRIED BY
WHEELED VEHICLES THAN NEED GOOD
ROADS.
>> Reporter: EVEN THE RUSSIANS
ADMIT THAT IN SOME AREAS, WET
CONDITIONS CAN BE A FACT AR.
>> IF YOU STUDIED GEOGRAPHY OF
THE AREA, ACTUALLY, THE SOUTHERN
PART OF BELARUS CLOSE TO THE
UKRAINIAN BORDER IS VERY SWAMPY
AREA, WHICH IS SHARDLY FITTING
FOR A CERTAIN ACTIVE ENGAGEMENT
OF TANKS AND OTHER HEAVY
WEAPONRY.
>> I NOT JUST THE CONDITIONSING
O.
IT'S THE SKIES AS WE WANT.
CLEAR SKIES ARE IMPORTANT FOR
RECONNAISSANCE AND
INTELLIGENCE-GATHERING AND
LANDING ASSAULT TROOPS.
>> CLOUDY WEATHER, RAIN, SNOW,
ALL OF THAT WOULD INHIBIT THE
RECONNAISSANCE MEASURES THAT YOU
WOULD USE TO FIND THE TARGETS
AND IF YOU CAN'T FIND THE
TARGETS PRECISELY, THE EFFECT
THAT YOUR FIRES ARE GOING TO
HAVE ARE GOING TO BE DIMINISHED.
>> BUT IN THE INITIAL PHASE OF
ANY CONFLICT, SOME EXPERTS SAY
RUSSIA WOULD LIKELY OFFER
WEAPONS THAT CAN OPERATE IN ANY
WEATHER, LONG RAGE ARTILLERY,
BALLISTIC MISSILES, THEY WOULD
SEEK TO TAKE OUT UKRAINIAN
CONTROL, NOT FRONT LINE FORCES,
SATELLITE IMAGERY INDICATES SOME
WEAPONS HAVE BEEN BROUGHT
FORWARD TO POSITIONS NEAR THE
UKRAINIAN BORDER.
TODAY, EVEN AS THE WORLD
CONTINUES TO LOOK AT THAT
MILITARY BUILDUP, CONTINUES TO
LOOK AT THE WEATHER AND THE
CONDITIONS HERE ON THE GROUND IN
UKRAINE TO TRY AND FIGURE OUT
WHAT IS ON VLAD SLD'S MIND, ALSO
THE ANNOUNCEMENTS WE HEARD FROM
THE RUSSIAN FOREIGN MINISTRY
SAYING THE ONUS IS ON UKRAINE TO
SEND BACK THE WEAPONRY SENT BY
ITS ALLIES OVER THE COURSE OF
THE LAST FEW WEEKS, IF IT WANTS
TO SEE DEESCALATION.
ALL OF THAT TELLS US WE WAIT TO
SEE WHAT PUTIN WANTS.
WHAT IS CERTAIN IS FOR THE TIME
BEING, THE PRESSURE IS K